[Music]
I
know
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet d value taming giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to haters run homie look
what I become I'm I'm the
one okay so our guest today is a special
guest Dr nuriel rubini let me properly
introduce him he is a Turkish born
Iranian American Economist writer and
economic consultant he's a professor
emeritus uh at Stern School of Business
of New York uh University NYU and the
founder of chairman of rubini global
economics and independent Global
macroeconomics
uh and Market strategy research firm he
is best known for predicting the 20072
2008 subprime mortgage crisis in us and
subsequent Global financial crisis is
also known for warning about other
economic risks such as the European debt
crisis Chinese economic slowdown the
potential for a stag inflationary
environment he's highly respected
Economist and his views are often sought
by policy makers and investors around
the world he's been named one of the top
100 most influential people by Time
Magazine and one of the 50 most
influential Global thinkers by uh
foreign policy he has written New York
time bestselling uh he's a New York time
bestell and author written several books
on economics and finance including uh
crisis economics a crash course in the
future of Finance Mega threats and a
bunch of other books he is highly
accomplished Economist and his work has
significant impact on our understanding
of the global economy he has a couple
nicknames he's you know very few people
have multiple nicknames he's got one uh
uh that that's very known Dr Doom of
Economics uh some people have called him
this is an interesting one I got to tell
you the more I read about you the more
interesting you are to me rubini was
described by a journalist helain Olen as
having an accent REM reminiscent of
James Bond villain okay so I don't know
what that accent's going to be like but
the Dr Doom nickname have you always Mr
Dr Rin have you always been this
optimistic and positive about the future
well thanks very much for being on your
podcast first of all um um you know I'm
an economist and as an economist you
have to think about what can go right
and what can go wrong in the world you
have to do scenario analysis there are
downside risk there are upside risk but
in studying the US and the global
economy I've realized that over time
some of the downside risks are becoming
more severe than the upside risk and the
kind of relative economic and financial
stability that we had in the 1950s and
60s has given way to periods of time of
much greater economic and financial and
monetary volatility and instability we
have had economic and financial crisis
both in advanced economies and emerging
market for the last 20 years they're
becoming more frequent they're becoming
more virulent and we have to address
them and also I realized and that was
the subject matter of my last book Mega
threads that in addition to the economic
monetary and Financial Risk we live in a
world in which there are social risks
political
geopolitical
environmental health
technological and Military and that's
why my book addresses both economic and
non-economic one we live in a very
dangerous world so we have to be aware
of what's can go wrong for every problem
there are potential Solutions they're
not easy they're not cheap they're not
expensive so I prefer to be called I
would say Dr realist rather than Dr Doom
but I guess the moniker of Dr Doom is
more catchy and that's why people keep
on using it I I like it though I like Dr
Doom to me it's more like a
movie I can see you being an Avengers I
can see it being if I was your manager I
would say let's stick to Dr Doom we can
Market that more and uh do bigger things
but but anyways I appreciate that again
I appreciate you for being on we've been
following your work for a while and uh
you know my question I got just to open
up with a lot of times like when you go
to a a doctor and a doctor that's seen a
thousand patients 2,000 patients you'll
say you know this part of my body hurts
this is what I'm experiencing and then
instantly by three questions have are
you having spasms here could be this
let's test this let's do an MRI let's do
that but for the most part A Doctor Who
has been around for 30 years is going to
have enough case studies to go to to say
the trends of what you're talking about
the symptoms matches this symptom that
I've seen with 78 patients before right
and let's kind of get clear on what's
going on here and we get to the bottom
of it today I'm not sure if we have
another case study like this it would
have to be outside of the us where we
printed as much money as we did during
coid trillions of dollars seen some
numbers that said we printed 40% of
course it's not all paper some of it is
digital but still we've seen what the
numbers are we've never printed that
kind of money before we've never had
interest rates be at zero or one for as
long as it did you know the economic
expansion
128% I'm not sure it's good to keep
interest rates that low for that long
we've never seen people staying home
during Co the way they did everybody all
of a son wanting to work from home we've
not experienced that simultaneously the
advancement of AI coming the way it is
the conflict we're having you know with
Ukraine Russia and then Israel Iran all
hitting at the same time you know a lot
of people right now are not selling
their homes we have mortgage rates at a
27 not not even mortgage rates mortgage
application at a 27e low like there is
no mortgage applications coming in real
estate sales are at a 20-year low we're
not selling a lot of homes right now
because people don't want to give up
that 3% right so well we think the
Market's going to crash and real
estate's going crash and property value
is going to come down it's not gradually
we're seeing some stuff that's going on
with commercial that they're defaulting
in and some subprime auto payments what
other case study does somebody like you
who this is your world what do you look
at to say no Patrick we've seen this
here we've seen this aspect here in what
happened in Venezuela we've seen this
what happened in Japan we've seen this
that happened here and we feel based on
these markers this is what's most likely
going to be happening so one the
question would be what case study do you
look at and two based on that case study
what are some possibilities of what
could happen with today's
economy um you're right in suggesting
that the times might be different today
as I argue my mega thread books there's
bit of a regime change in the world
economy and the World At Large but of
course there are hundreds of episodes of
Economic and financial crisis the whole
economic history of events have occurred
for the last few decades and there are
some similarities and there are some
differences but in terms of differences
I would say that uh uh you know I grew
up between Middle East and Europe I was
born 19 58 and then for the first 24
years of my life I was mostly then in
Europe and Middle East and I came to us
for grat schol around
1983 uh but you know when I was growing
up the risk of say a War nuclear war
among great power had gone away because
in the 70s you the the taunt between the
Soviet Union us then Nixon went to China
and therefore while there were Rivals of
us Soviet Union China communist it was
no risk of a of a military war or a
nuclear war today as you know there is
already a hot war between Russia and
Ukraine this hot War could become
unconventional could involve NATO uh
where to see the beginning of a war
between not just Israel and Hamas but it
could extend to esbah and involve Iran
that will be a second front uh there's a
cold war between us and China is getting
colder under some scenario there's even
risk that China invades Taiwan and then
if you respond you have a hot war with
us and China and you have this little
dictator North Korea keeps on sending
rockets and as nuclear bombs towards the
sea of Japan and Korea so there are four
strategic rival of the US and the West
that are nuclear armed one is not yet
but may become soon Iran and therefore
today the risk of War among great Powers
all nuclearly TI is higher than ever
before uh another difference you know
when I was growing up in the 60s and 70s
there was barely any mention of global
climate change you know temperature were
barely above Industrial Level today we
already 1.5 above pre industrial going
to go towards two or more uh it's a
disaster it's slow motion train wreck
you know when I was growing up I never
heard about global pandemics the last
one had been the Spanish Flu in
19819 you knew it only in the history
books since 1980 we have had HIV SARS
Mars swine flu bird flu zika Eola coid
19 it's not going to be the last one for
a reason we can discuss there'll be more
vent ones uh you know uh AI you know
today people worry that AI eventually is
going to become super intelligent is
going to make the human species homo
Sapient obsolete when I was growing up
we're in the middle of AI winter right
there was barely some research about it
nobody really thought there was not even
a personal computer let alone the
internet therefore the idea that machine
can threaten our jobs our incomes and
our lives was totally farfetched we're
mostly at that time in stable uh liberal
democracies at least in in the west and
the kind of radical extremist populism
of either extreme right or left that you
see all over the world was not uh was
not prevalent yes there were some
authoritarian countries Soviet Union
communist China but they tend to be the
exception rather than rule in US Europe
Advanced economy was political stability
and today instead where polarization
part partisanship and populism that is
radical and extreme and even economic
and financial Cycles were much more mild
we did not have the severe recession the
severe financial crisis we've seen in
the last 30 years so it was a very
different world and today is a world in
which the threats are much more severe
so in some sense yes we project from the
past and believe that the recent past is
going to imply the way the future is
going to be and with all the ups and
downs we have had 75 75 years of
relative peace progress and prosperity
since World War II and we hope that the
future is going to be like the recent
past but there may be a regime change
and the kind of threats that are
emerging are very different than the
last 75 80 years so so when you when you
think about that as a consumer okay so
the feedback I'd want to like give to
the consumer and even from
you it would be would it be fair to say
don't don't believe anything any experts
or economists are saying right now 100%
because everybody could be right and
everybody could be wrong right a group
could be right and a group could be
could be wrong because it's so hard to
predict what's going to happen you know
we're having a conversation yesterday
about you know what happened to uh
Venezuela stock market how earlier this
year was at 10,000 right now it's at 63
64,000 and that's a reversal market
crash where the market crashes up and
then the rich get richer the poor get
poorer where my one of my concerns is
what happens if power like you know how
all these knobs we control you know when
you're on a plane you're looking at the
pilots they're controlling all these
knobs and you're like okay there's
probably five knobs that are the most
important knobs to a pilot there's
important knobs to a tanker or a driver
or anybody that has a knob in America
when it comes on to the economy there's
a hand full of knobs one of the knobs is
the interest rate that's a very powerful
knob right if you increase it you
decrease it your own pal that's a knob
we have a few other knobs that we can
look at we feed you know whether it's
quantitative easing or tightening we put
money in or we took money
out how bad do you think a the market
would be if in the next 6 12 months
because pow right now is trying to raise
the rates to bring inflation down to 2%
you're saying it's mathematically
impossible I read in an article you said
it's not going to happen back to we have
to it's going to be back absolutely
impossible to get to 2% just controlling
not with interest rates it's not moving
it that much uh but slightly how bad
would it be if he brought the rates back
down to levels we were at a year and a
half ago say 4% say even 3% would the
Dow suddenly go to 40 45,000 because my
biggest concern is uh with everything
that's going on the economy some of the
behaviors before that you would see hey
gold should go to $50,000 $5,000 it's
not moving Bitcoin should go to $100,000
it hited
$355,000 but the the knobs that would
typically move certain things are not
doing it right now so what are some of
the knobs you worry about the most that
if we screw up can really affect the
economy um you made many points so
interesting and and valid um first of
all the world is
uncertain uh but I wouldn't go as far as
saying we cannot trust anybody of course
even among uh professional economists
and Senior ones there can be a spectrum
of use but I'd rather to listen to an
economist that has views different from
me and I can have a dialogue with him or
her sure on why they come to certain
conclusion rather than other ones but I
don't trust those who pretend to be
expert who don't know anything you know
unfortunately today on Twitter anybody
can go and Bash me and attack me
whether you like it or not you know I've
been studying do research economics PhD
at Harvard y NYU White House treasury
International Organization for 50 years
so understand certain things doesn't
mean I'm right all the time of course
not uh doesn't mean that other people
may be right of course that's why we
have an intelligent dialogue among
people who are understanding these
issues and they are experts so I don't
believe in the idea that anybody can say
anything just because the experts are
all on wrong at least economists even
when they disagree they have a parameter
of discussing why they disagree on what
and I'll give you the specific example
you know about predicting the future is
hard think about what the FED is trying
to do they're trying to achieve uh
inflation back to 2% without a recession
what they call it soft Landing so
there's one scenario where you have a
soft Landing you go back to 2% without a
recession gold the locks IM Mar that is
inflation there's another scenario of
The Other Extreme that as you try to
raise rates to fight inflation it caused
not only an economic crisis recession
but also a financial crisis because the
interest rates people have to pay on
their debts household corporates
financial institution government becomes
too high so you have an economic and
financial crisis called the hard landing
and then there's a middle scenario of a
softish landing or a bmy landing where
we go back to 2 % but we do so uh only
through a short and shallow recession
not a severe one not a financial crisis
and so on now the world could be more
than these three scenarios but just
let's simplify to these three scenarios
then you can discuss whether the Fred is
doing too much or too little if they do
too much and they really want to fight
inflation they have a risk of killing
the economy and cause a financial crisis
if they don't raise interest rates
enough because they care about economic
growth and financial stability
the risk is that there is a de anchoring
of inflation inflation expectation wage
price spiral and we end up with high
inflation so you have many objectives
you want price stability inflation 2%
growth stability uh no recession because
recession leads to unemployment is
painful and you want Financial stability
uh that is avoiding financial crisis in
banking stresses and you have one
instrument in principle the FED funds
rate can you achieve all those three
targets one instrument maybe yes maybe
not depends on many factors so my point
is you have to be really sophisticated
you cannot be just judgmental and
generic you have to do scenario analysis
I provideed you with three of them you
have to assign
probabilities and then those
probabilities change as the facts change
say a year ago the hardland they look
like a likely scenario because we the
spiking all energy food prices and
inflation because in part of the Russian
invasion of Ukraine six months ago we
had banking stresses with few Banks
going bu so many people thought we're
going to have a real recession then the
policy response more flexibility in some
markets uh some adjustment have implied
that now it look like maybe a short and
shallow recession and the latest number
actually suggest the US economic growth
is still above potential around three
rather than two and inflation is still
falling
because some of those negative Supply
shocks that it US during coid are being
reversed and the price wage spir is
going downward rather than upward so
more economies are actually of the view
that we may even avoid the bumpy Landing
with a short and shallow recession we
may actually have this Immaculate this
inflation and still grow at potential
avoid recession and go back to 2% so you
have to be as I say
nuanced I I I like that on what you just
said Rob did you get a text by Brandon
on a statistic number that just came
back recently maybe I'll show it in a
minute here it's very I really want to
get your feedback on this one when when
I get the statistic chart I'll show it
to you I think uh uh you may have some
commentary on it by the way in regards
to in regards to real estate okay in
regards to real
estate um very different than 2008 right
I mean 2008 we're dealing with neam you
know people are paying the minimum uh
instead of the interest only or the
30-year fix or the 15 year you know that
whole four pick a payment mortgage that
we had that turned into a movie Big
Short that did very well it was a book
then a movie fantastic movie and a book
and and and you look at today's real
estate obviously a lot of our audience
that listens to this they're small
business owners some of them want to buy
a house some of them want to sell their
house but a lot of them are also within
the real estate market whether they're
loan officers or they're on the real
estate side so what what do you like
let's just say I'm your son okay and I'm
your family I know you don't have any
kids but let's just say you know I'm
related to you you you're truly care
about me making the right decision I
come to you and I say uncle I got a
question for you I respect you a lot I'm
thinking about buying a house right now
you know should I buy right now should I
wait right now based on you haven't been
in this industry and and you know the
industry of economy seeing what's going
on with rates you know prices are not
lowering people are not selling um
there's not a lot of inventory out there
inventory is super low uh everyone's
waiting they're thinking the interest
rates are going to come down buyers are
thinking sellers are going to lower
their prices and some Pockets they're
lowering prices what what do you think
is going to happen to the real estate
market the next 6 12 18
months um well um my answer to that
question will be that uh the situation
today for real estate and I'm talking
about the residential of course there is
also commercial real estate that's a
different story retail
and office space and things of that sort
if you're looking at
residential I would say the good news
might be that things are not going to
get bad as bad as they did during the uh
subprime bubble and bu and the global
financial crisis because in that episode
what happened was that the bubble in
home prices was much worse than today
there might be some froess in home
prices today but let's say the ratio
between average price of a home to the
average household income or the ratio
between the price of homes to rents was
really stratospherically out of place
two uh as prices were going higher there
was a massive increase in the supply
much more many new homes being built and
that Supply was going into speculative
demand people buying homes just for say
condo flipping so once once it burst and
the speculative demand disappeared the
excess supply of housing implied that
the price collapsed 20
30% many people were essentially having
no equity in their homes they could not
essentially pay their mortgages they
walked away from their homes and once we
the recession was severe people didn't
have the income to pay also for their
homes so we had a real severe recession
bust of housing today instead
first of all those measure of a bubble
in the housing market are showing froess
but not a massive bubble like or6 or8
two uh the economy is still growing so
the household might have a balance sheet
problem the interest rates are starting
to pay on the mortgages is higher but if
you have a job and income you can still
afford it three when interest rates were
very low and you know as of two years
ago you could get as a prime borrower
say you could get a 10year mortgage for
two and a half to 3% today is 78 uh many
people locked in mortgages a long
maturity 10 20 30 years at interest
rates they're much lower so the average
person is not paying seven eight% the
average is paying something like between
three and four some people less some
people more and people have jobs so are
we going to have a downturn in real
estate yes is it going to be more severe
in in commercial uh meaning offices and
and uh stores and so on yes could there
be risk also for housing yes but if we
avoid a real recession people have jobs
and income and have now locked in
interest rates are lower as some of
those mortgages refinanced then people
are gonna find much more expensive to
pay their mortgages and today I would
say uh given the ratio between prices
and
rents it's much more how to say uh much
more for an individual to rent rather
than buy you want to wait to buy only
when mortgage rates are lower or prices
have fallen 10 15% so if I had to give
an advice to anybody I would say rent
today wait until mortgage rates are
lower and all prices of Home are lower
is not a good time to buy
and and and I don't know if you saw the
numbers it said what 52% cheaper right
now to rent to buy yeah that's correct
and there's there's other stats that
support um uh what you're saying right
now uh in America 61% of the total
mortgages in America are held at under
4% what percentage 61% are held under 4%
and 81% or under 5% and if you looked at
it as a band about a quarter of them are
3% to 2 and a half%
38% of them are 3 to four and 20% are 4
to 5 so to your point sir um you know
people that go say from um migration
north to south they could Airbnb which
is a another phrase for just rent your
old home and you know uh if you're a
retired person rent something in any of
the Southern sunb belt where you go for
your Winters when you um not for a uh
you know extravagance just as you go for
the for the winter the way the um the
retired folks go the other side of it is
there's a little bit of a tick up in
foreclosures for subprime but I read
this morning that even if they if that
Peaks out it probably only adds 50% to
the current inventory which would still
keep it like only 40% of the historical
average so in other words if the
subprime inventory comes out through
foreclosures yes it the inventory for
sale right now is still so low it's just
going to bring it up a little bit and
it's going to be more it's not going to
be dramatic where it's going to be felt
spot Market the other thing I read that
was very interesting is who owns the
houses that are being for that are that
are being discounted the homeowner
discounts the rates much slower and it
was the Foreclosure glut and the banks
that dumped the um assets they were
holding because you and I have a bank
all of a sudden we have four houses and
no and no um uh mortgage behind them
we're like holy crap we sell them and we
dropped the price so the banks were the
ones that started the snowball of the
price dropping because Pat and Tom's
Bank we're not making interest on that
we got property talks that we got
insurance get this thing off my balance
sheet and we and so we tossed it out I
want to show this I want to show this Dr
uh uh norel if you can if you can pull
this up Rob I know I'm not going to be
able to see it as long as he sees it
that's what I care about I saw this the
other day and for me I'm always
wondering you know who is going to
predict the recession uh uh more
accurately do they know something the
rest of us don't know as long as you see
it I'm good whenever you see it if you
can just tell me you see it uh uh it
should say what's next for the US
economy 2024 projections are you able to
see it uh not yet okay Rob let me know
when you have it so he can see it on
this chart before he brings it up I'll
just read it to you it shows uh seven
different brackets and these brackets
it's shown what is the percentage who
thinks a recession is coming okay fed
staff 0% they don't think recession is
coming this is people that work for the
FED they don't think a recession is
going to be coming uh yield curve 7 61%
Economist uh economists think 48% chance
a recession is coming consumers 69%
chance they think a recession is coming
Goldman Sachs is only at 15% Bank of
America is at 35 to 40% however
CEOs of larger companies they're at 84%
CEOs of larger companies are at 84% so
why would CEOs of larger companies be at
84% what do they knew that the rest of
us don't know now if you uh of course
you know study this um a lot of these
companies when money was so cheap
everybody was saying guys let's go get
some money let's go get some money let's
go get some money let's go get some
money money is so
cheap some of them put it to work some
of them you know put it in a you know
Treasury and they made interest on it
but for the most part some of these guys
are paying interest rates that they're
worried if the if it gets called a year
from now six months from now their
interest on the loan that they took some
numbers have shown it's going to go from
530 billion this year to 780 billion
next year then it's going to crack a
trillion one then a trillion three in
the next three years and these are
interest payments that they have to be
paying that's a lot of money why do you
think CEOs
who are in the business think a
recession is more likely than the rest
of the other seven
communities yes I mean first of all that
chart shows that there is a whole
distribution of views among different
groups even among economists some are
optimistic some are pessimistic I'm sure
that's the case also among a variety of
cvos so the honest answer is as I said
when it comes to predicting the future
you can only do a bunch of scenarios and
try to assess probabilities six months
ago the staff of the FED had a recession
short and shallow as being their
Baseline today instead they say their
Baseline is no recession so that
probably has gone for them not to zero
but their Baseline is a a soft Landing
rather than a short and shallow
recession additional point when people
say there'll be a recession is going to
be short and shallow it's going to be
more severe associated with a banking
financial crisis or not and is a
recession next 12 months as opposed to
after the presidential elections if a
recession were to occur before the next
presidential election it's going to have
impact on whether it's going to be Trump
or Biden winning even a short and
shallow recession it occurs in 2025 the
implications are going to be different
so so even the question has to be more
specific I think that the the the the
CEOs in my view are concerned about
several things first of all um while
during the global financial crisis the
problem was too much debt of
households uh you know mortgages and
lending by the banks in the last 105
years there has been a massive buildup
of corporate debt Corporation have
borrowed like crazy and they've been
financed less by Banks and more by what
people call Shadow Banks non Bank Bank
financial institutions a variety of
capital markets hedge funds private
Equity firms and you name it uh there is
already a lot of debt that is what's
called Junk bonds below investment rate
of people that have so much debt that is
risky and the spreads that you have to
pay on it is much higher than investment
rate there's a trillion dollar of what
people call Fallen Angels uh thatb and
firms that were investment grade enough
been downgraded to junk level uh there
is another trillion dollar of corporate
debt that is barely investment grade one
step from being downgraded and in the
private Market there's been a massive
buildup of private debt not financed by
Banks or Capital markets and things like
what people exotic instrument like
Leverage loans
Clos peer-to-peer private debt a lot of
it has been done in very risky ways
without safe covenants so and some of
these debt by the corporate sector like
the household during the coid crisis was
refinanced at lower interest rates at
longer maturity but several trillion
dollars of this corporate debt is coming
now to maturity in the next one two
three years and so on and if interest
rates remain high those firms that were
borrowing at low rates like household
will have to refinance themselves at
much higher rate now like for the
household sector today there is a
balance sheet problem you have a lot of
debt and the interest rate on that debt
is rising but you don't have yet a p&l
problem meaning an income side because
the economy is still growing profits are
still positive revenues are growing so
yes corporates like hous are strained on
the balance sheet high debt and
gradually interest rates going higher
but as long as houses have jobs and
incomes rather being unemployed as long
as firms have Revenue growth and profits
they can still manage the interest
payments on those liabilities If instead
there is a recession you get a double
wamy a shock to your balance sheet high
debt and Rising interest payments on the
debt and then a hit to your income
statement your Revenue your income your
profit your employment and then you get
into a s
financial distress so the bad news debt
ratios are high and that servicing RTI
are rising the good news is that income
revenues profits are still rising and
therefore for now even the corporate
sector can afford it but CEOs are
becoming nervous that eventually this
large stock of debt and high interest
rates is going to become unsustainable
they also look at Global risk of various
sorts and of course the geopolitical
risk are a thre if Energy prices were to
rise even more so because there is a
regional war between Israel us and Iran
not just against Hamas that shock to all
prices is going to lead to inflation
recession stock flation like the 1970s
this is some of the thing that might be
on the mind of the corporate leaders
yeah that's on the mind of the CEO I
have a question for you and that's
what's on your mind uh a year ago you
like many others and I was kind of in
this Camp you saw all the things you
articulated and you thought that this
year could be a pretty you know hard
Landing recession now it appears that it
extended the uh the stimulus took
consumer credit card debt all the way
down to 300 excuse me 400 billion but
now the consumer has spent that all the
way up to 1 trillion uh really driving
what appears to be third quarter and
then you've got the things that you just
talked about that so the consumer may
have a little bit more Runway because
they've got a p&l and the interest rates
on their debt is rising grad ually so
this consumers probably got some time
but it doesn't sound like you think
corporates got a lot of time what do you
think is coming for next year you think
it's going to be a soft Landing but I'm
hearing between the lines I think you've
got some thoughts in there that may be
more severe for the corporate sector did
I hear
that yes I would say if we go back to
the three scenarios I described before a
real hard Landing a short and shallow
recession call it softish or bump
landing and real soft Landing I would
say that the good news compared to a
year ago when we had the spiking
inflation and Rising commodity prices or
six months ago when we were worried that
the banking problem would lead to a
credit Crunch and a crash of the economy
is that the tail risk of a real hard
Landing today looks much lower than it
was and the stimulus the fiscal might be
part of the story so then the question
is say think about the next next year or
so through the end of 24 do we get
really a soft Landing or a short and
shallow recession uh I would say the
consensus move towards the soft Landing
but there are scenarios under which you
could still get the short and shallow
recession you get a short and shallow
recession for the following reason you
could be in a situation in which suppose
that this conflict in the Middle East
gets worse and O prices have already
risen by 10% compared to the pre
barbaric attack of Israel by Hamas
suppose that they go up by 20% or more
then you have two shocks one inflation
is rising two those who are users of
energy households and those firms that
are energy users in the US have a shock
to their income as well because it's
more expensive to buy energy so you have
a stationary shock that reduces income
and increases inflation cost of
production
then the FED has a dilemma you want to
fight inflation you have to raise rates
more but they already high and that
creates distress and if you don't raise
them because you're worried about growth
then you can have a de unor of inflation
expectation and a wage price spiral so
the trade-off becomes more difficult for
the
fed the econom is already gonna slow
down in the fourth quarter because of a
bunch of headwinds Not Just Energy
prices most likely we're going to have a
government sh down uh the GOP doesn't
even have a speaker even if they have
one there'll be a collision course with
the Democrats so we get a government
shutdown get energy prices rising we
have Labor
Strife uh with strikes in a number of
sectors uh student loan repayment have
to start that's a drug of 50 billion on
the on the economy and Rising interest
rates are becoming a burden both for
households and for corporates will have
to start cutting back on consumption
cutting back on Capital spending cutting
back on hiring so you get a slow down of
the economy slowly slowly and then there
are all these new uncertainties coming
from the Middle East that require in
uncertain people like to wait is the
option value of waiting they might do
less capex less production less
employment less consumption they may
save more and then it becomes
self-fulfilling so I would say for now
the economy has been growing above
potential Q3 actually could be very
strong Q4 is going to be probably weak
and then depending what happens to the
Middle East uh what happens to inflation
whether the FED can stay on hold from
here as opposed to hiking more you may
end up in a soft Landing or you might
end up into a short and shallow
recession and those are the factors they
have to keep in mind as you asking
yourself whether it's one or the
other what do you think is the highest
probability I mean that's a that's a
wide analysis what do you think the
highest probability for the US I mean no
Economist can say anything with
certainty of course but what do you
think the highest probability soft
landing and then corporate Banking and
corporations have a tough time adjusting
because they're carrying some of them a
trillion dollars of uh you know barely
above
junk um I would say right now the
situation my view is uh the probability
of a soft Landing I would give it an
Epsilon more than a short and shallow
recession say
5545 few months ago I would have said
the opposite but the economic data of
surprise on the upside there's also a
lot of fiscal stimulus in the pipeline
between the chips act the infrastructure
Act and the IRA and the IRA is going to
cost us not not 360 billion but it's
such a generous system of tax credit for
investing into energy that probably the
final cost is going to be over a
trillion over decade
and then you have the new investments in
AI that many firms are doing that are
also a positive uh and so on so I would
say a soft Landing as of now looks more
likely and the FED may be close to being
done with raising rates uh as long as
there is not a spike in inflation uh
rather than even a short and shallow
recession but I would say if Energy
prices go higher by another 10 to
20% uh compared to current level then
probably we get into a short and shallow
recession because then inflation is
higher the FED cannot just ignore it
they'll have to hike once or twice more
uh and they the rise in Energy prices
has a stronger impact on the users of
energy they will have to spend less then
on the producers of energy they'll have
a windfall of profit and revenues so the
net effect on the economy is weakening
the economy while raising inflation so
so I think think that what's happening
in the Middle East at this point is very
critical the banking problems we worried
about them but they're under control
right now a few Regional Banks went bust
the other ones were back stop the credit
crunch has not been so severe the big
banks are still have plenty of cash
plenty of capital so we're not gonna
have a banking problem as as of now but
if the FED were to raise interest rates
you know two or three or four times more
because inflation goes higher because
Energy prices go higher than then I
think we end up into a recession do do
you have for someone that you know uh
Turkish born Iranian American I read
somewhere I think you were also you also
lived in tan for a year if I'm not
mistaken uh uh where were yeah went from
Istanbul to Teran to Tel Aviv and then
Milano and after college I came to us
for grad school so got it quite yeah so
so you you've been in that that region I
lived in Iran for 10 years myself uh
born 78 uh 3 months later Ki obviously
comes in and the rest is history and
then we go to Germany to live in a
refugee camp what are your thoughts
about what's going on right now with
Israel uh Palestine and then the you're
someone that's gone to Harvard and you
know you you're not just anybody that
went to Harvard Professor there
respectable you you you went to school
there yourself uh um but you're seeing
the criticism that's happening within
schools universities kids taking
different sides uh many billionaires are
now saying I'm not going to be funding
schools whether it's Wharton whether
it's Harvard whether it's Yale it's not
like it's just one school it's a lot of
that taking place how are you processing
the current conflict taking place in
Israel and Palestine and
Hamas you know first of all as an
economist I have to ask myself what are
going to be the economic and financial
implication of this conflict regardless
of personal views you know I'm Jewish my
parents my sister 21st cousins live in
Israel you know I support strongly
Israel I think that this attack by Hamas
against Israel was totally barbaric
torture rape abuse something disgusting
barbaric but I also believe that
eventually there has to be a political
solution to the Palestinian problem with
a a two-state solution and maybe we need
a war to go to peace that's what
happened in 73 Egypt attacked Israel
restored their honor and then sadad went
and made peace with vin uh so maybe
we'll need a war until then we get rid
of Hamas and we can have more stable
Palestinian Authority in Gaza and resume
the normalization between Israel Saudi
us and the rest and then we can restore
the peace process at least that's my
hope uh as an economist I have to think
about scenarios I would say in principle
you have to think about two scenarios
scenario number one is one in which this
conflict remains limited to Gaza Israel
goes into Gaza try to dislodge as much
as it can of amamas try to eradicate it
amamas is been actually more of a curse
to the Palestinian in Gaza than to the
Israelis because has made their life
miserable and U it be painful hopefully
you can avoid and minimize the loss of
civilian life and all rest but as long
as remains contained just to Israel amas
in Gaza the macroeconomic implication
globally remain modest Market seems to
be pricing this scenario say oil prices
energy price have gone up by only 10%
compared to uh before the attack by amas
it's significant but is the fear premium
there is not yet a shock to the
production or Supply or exports of oil
and energy and gas from the Gulf is more
the fear premium that is spiking 10%
Energy prices and the movements in bond
yields in stock markets and gold has
been minimal when there was a panic gold
went higher and bond yields went lower
Equity corrected a little bit but now
good economic news on us show that bond
yields are going higher again Equity are
stronger and gold is moving sort of
sideways so the market seem to be
believing that the probability of a
conflict contained to essentially Gaza
is 80% probability even more the
probability of a regional conflict let
Al Global 10 20% maximum that's what the
markets Bond markets Equity markets oil
markets and gold markets are telling us
now Market can be wrong so that's a how
to say less dystopian scenario still
ugly painful but manageable both
geopolitically economic and financially
the second scenario is one in which Iran
decides that they cannot let Israel
completely eradicate Hamas as they've
been supporting it you know for decades
and the way to try to make it hard for
Israel to beat Hamas is to unleash
Hezbollah in Lebanon because then Israel
has to fight on two fronts South against
Hamas North against Hezbollah and esbah
is something like 100,000 Rockets not
10,000 or so so they're much more
powerful there could be even a third
front in the West Bank as well now if if
Iran decides that they have to
essentially support the proxy amas at
any cost and they unleash asalah not
only us and and Israel attack
esbah but then Israel and us have to
attack Iran why two reasons most likely
Iran was already behind the Hamas attack
against Israel and certainly will be
again behind the attack ofah against
Israel so a decision of isbah having a
full war with Israel is cannot be taken
without Iran agreeing on it and two Iran
at that point has to accelerate his own
nuclear
glorification glorification program
because they know they have to try to
get the bomb before Israel attacks them
and and by the way in the deal that us
did with Iran on releasing the six
hostages in exchange of or a few
hostages in exchange of six billion Iran
also committed to stop enrichment of
uranium to 60% not going to 90% weapon
grade not the US has pulled out of this
deal say no more six billion Iranians
can retaliate only by enriching uranium
so you have two reasons why Israel and
us have to strike Iran Iran Unleashed
esbah and is trying to fight Israel on
three fronts and is Iran is going to go
and build the bomb then if Israel and US
attack Iran then the production and
exports of oil from the Gulf streate of
ormos is blocked for a few weeks if not
few months depending on how severe this
conflict becomes becomes like
1973 yum keeper war or 1979 Iranian
Revolution where you had a doubling or
tripling in all prices and if that
happens then it's a regional conflict
oil doubles in price inflation goes to
the roof you have a US recession you
have a global recession and we have a
stock flation like we had in the 70s
stock flation means inflation and
recession and and then it becomes really
ugly becomes an economic and financial
crisis globally so the honest answer is
which one of these two scenarios more
likely the honest answer nobody knows
and you can try to assign probabilities
the market are saying the negative
scenario which everything goes wrong uh
is only 10 to 20% probability 80%
probability that the conflict is contain
to Gaza other people geopolitical expert
think that the second scenario is more
more likely um do do does anybody know
um not not clearly but it's a very very
different outlook for the US and the
global economy in one the impact is
really minimal on the economy on the
markets in the other one it's a total
disaster
yeah it's it's not a a it's not
a pretty face when you're looking at it
right now it's not looking good at all
and um a lot of people are concerned but
again if you're saying 10 to 20% the way
the markets react and saying they're
going to figure out a way to have a
peace treaty or you know kind of uh
finish this on and move on it doesn't
look like Israel wants to do that it it
almost seems like Israel wants to uh
impose because they're not happy by what
Hamas did and they want to defend their
position but again we're going to see
what's going to happen with no but is
Israel is going to go after Hamas
they'll have to invade Gaza they have to
try to limit and they will try civilian
deaths because Israel doesn't want to
kill civilians and unfortunately Hamas
uses them as human Shields but say the
conflict in Gaza could become painful
and ugly and whatever but eventually
there'll be a ceasefire eventually
hopefully most of Massa is eradicated
maybe you get Saudis Egyptians and
moderate Palestinians from West
controlling and providing security to
Gaza after Israel has done the clean up
and then you have pay pay a part either
for at least a ceasefire and or then
resuming a priest process but the
economic implication however Ugly Things
become for Israel and for gazans are
contained uh so I'm not saying it's a
nice scenario but is contained it
doesn't have Global Consequence the
other scenario you get the global
station global recession and high
inflation it's a it's real disaster for
the world you know when I was talking to
Ray Dalo one of the things he was
talking about is how closely he also
watches the political side of how it
affects the economy right I mean you
have to almost pay attention to see
what's going on with politics in this
region in China and this and that in
Middle East how how uh how does this
impact 2024 we're 12 months away right
give or take 12 months and a week 12
months yeah exactly 12 months 53 54
weeks away from election how does this
impact elections negatively
positively uh no impact what do you
think the impact of this is on the
election you know it's complicated I
would say that um assuming that um
Democrats nominate Biden and Republican
nominate Trump that's the Baseline for
now um the key things probably that
determine the results of the election
are first of all the economy secondly of
course uh you know the campaign and the
debates are going to be mattering as
well which one of the two candidate
looks stronger in debates or in a
campaign but I think that's going to be
a bit of a wash the economy is a first
order magnitude and then foreign policy
issues also can matter as well directly
indirectly now I would say the economy
for
now is doing okay is not great but
growth is about potential unemployment
rate is low job creation is still solid
wage growth is fine now and so on so the
economy is doing reasonably well so that
should be favoring Biden what could der
rail the economy I would say is not the
FED directly is more the Middle East as
I said if oil goes up by another 20%
Then inflation is rising the economy is
weakening and the fed them if you do
them if you don't if you raise rates the
recession becomes more severe if you
don't raise rates then inflation goes
higher and that's also painful so the
Middle East first of all can derail the
economy uh and that's one direct effect
uh two of course the Middle East matters
because then you have a foreign policy
kind of Crisis where the Russian
invasion of Ukraine brutal now you have
another conflict I would say that the
reaction of the president so far has
been quite strong even Republicans
believe that you know the strong of
Israel has been the right thing to do
but you know the same way the Ukraine
thing became partisan unfortunately
because we should be supporting Ukraine
even the Middle East could become part
partisan I'm sure Trump is going to say
it's your fault by trying to have a
dialogue with Iran we we look like we
were appeasing Iran and then they amas
attacks thing is unfair criticism I
think that Trump getting out of the
joint comprehensive plan of action was
actually big mistake but that's a
personal view because then uh Iran
became even more
radicalized but you know foreign policy
uh if there is a total disaster in the
Middle East they could blame it on the
president but so far I think the
president has taken an approach that is
the right one and supported by by by
most Americans and so on so the key
thing I think is really the economy and
whether they a recession and that
depends in part on what's going to
happen in the Middle East so the results
of the depend on the economy and the
biggest threat to the economy right now
is probably a conflict in the Middle
East that Spikes all prices and leads to
inflation and recession then you know
Carter lost his election in U in in the
second term when IR ran again because
not not only you had the hostage crisis
but more importantly you had the Iranian
Revolution that led to a shock to the
production of oil doubling of O prices
inflation and recession
that was the trigger for Carter losing
to Ronald Reagan and a Carter beat
Ford because we had the first all shock
of 1973 as well and that rightly or
wrongly was blamed on the sitting
president General Ford so the Middle
East can really affect the results of
the US election when Carter beat Ford
and when Reagan bit Carter it could
happen again uh next year meaning it
could happen where Trump beats Biden
again next year kind of like uh oh
you're saying Carter beating Ford is
what you're saying so some would say I
mean if you look at the uh Washington
Post just came out saying Biden's
economy is great everywhere uh except in
the polls and I think this is a couple
days ago as the US economy continues to
improve President Joe Biden continues to
not uh get credit for it only 35% of
Voters in seven swing States trust Biden
on the economy according to a Bloomberg
morning consult poll with 51% saying it
was better under Trump that
16% uh difference and it's a it's a wo
talking about this and Bloomberg talking
about this so why do you think the
American voter doesn't trust Biden on
the
economy um you know polls you know first
of all can change over time I think that
the economy did well under Trump but of
course then you had the co crisis was an
external shock to a recession since then
we've had a recovery from the coid
crisis growth has been
robust uh unemployment is low job
creation good of course inflation for a
while led to a reduction in real wages
and people felt the pain of inflation
now luckily inflation is falling it's
still above a Target but core is getting
close to three so I think some of the
males is a males that comes from the
recent increase in inflation and erosion
of real wages in us we also have a large
amount of income and wealth inequality
that's not because of Biden or Trump is
more structural but I think that even if
you have jobs there is a feeling that
the middle class or the working class
are sort of Left Behind that neither
party uh cares about them I would say
Biden's policies you know Trump run as a
populist and then he govern as a
plutocrat giving tax cuts most ly for
Corporation Biden has to his own
industrial policy tried to rebuild the
industrial base of the country and new
factors in manufacturing jobs are being
created but the average American is
still quite cranky because uh he worried
about still inflation being too high
he's worried about all these economic
and political and geopolitical
uncertainties uh there is now meaningful
amount of income and wealth inequality
and there is resentment against it and
uh and usually people tend to overall
blame whoever is in power because the
back stops there as well so so I would
say you know the the results of the
presidential election depend of course
on five to seven swing
States um which direction they're going
to go uh is not clear economic issues
May
matter uh and those SP suggest that
while the Eon is doing well uh only part
of Americans are supportting by in those
swing States but then many people
believe that in those swing States
soccer moms independent voters and
others find that the the brand of
populism of trump is also quite toxic is
a divider and many of them were put off
by him in 2020 were put off by him in
2022 and they might vote for Biden in
2024 so I would say the results of the
24 election are totally open whether
it's going to be Biden or Trump uh is
all to be seen right I agree I do think
it's going to be totally open by the way
have you have you seen studying the
economy last 50 years us having this
many strikes in a year you UAW writers
actors uh uh FedEx you know UPS who else
is the recent one Kaiser Permanente
75,000 of them I mean left and right
there's so many strikes that are taking
place have you ever seen a time where
we've had this many strikes at the same
time
well you know in the 70s there was a lot
of Labor Strife uh but I think the
reason why we're seeing this type of
Labor Strife not just us but also in
Europe is that you know for the last few
decades there's been a massive increase
in income and wealth inequality real
wages have not grown very much
regardless of who was in power profits
has grown a lot the share of Labor
income as a share of overall income has
gone down the share of wages have gone
down the share of profit and capital has
gone up and there is more more more
inequality and I think
that that's that's something that leads
to political resentment against it not
only among Democrats you know one of the
reasons why you know the GOP used to be
the party of Wall Street and big
business and small business um and now
it's become the party instead of
economic populism right of the Left
Behind the blue collar and white collars
so saying we want policies in our favor
uh bashing big business against free
trade against migration against things
that usually the GOP standed for why
those who are suffering are not
just uh white collar and blue collar
that are socially more Progressive and
vote
Democrats uh but also many people that
are socially conservative feel they're
left behind and they want economic
populism and the economic policy at Le
the rhetoric of trump was economic
populism and nationalism and
protectionism you name it so you know
the economic policies of Bernie Sanders
are not very different from those of
Donald Trump at least those that he
pretends to have and Biden has taken
some of the same economic populism and
bomic in part is I care about you about
workingclass I want to create jobs in
manufacturing I want to restore it I
want to invest in our infrastructure I
want to produce more chips more energy
more alternative and so on and so on so
so you know economic populism and
Industrial policy is something that both
Republican and Democrat sort of agree on
let's say fair free
capitalism is out of the window not only
among Democrats but even among
Republicans yeah it's it's funny you say
that when you say you know GOP was about
Wall Street it was this it was that I
mean I would even add GOP Maybe
some would say censorship and for war
and it's almost like flip today it's
more Democrats that are for war for
censorship for Wall Street they're
controlled by them and it's very
confusing for the voter on what's going
on but Tom you had a question about go
ahead you were going to say something
but yeah so Tom Tom you had a question
about immigration on you know how how
you know the the amount of people that
are coming across and then you know Dr
Rini talked about how immigration is a
good thing we're getting a lot of
workers what what question did you have
well the question I had most recently
you talked about immigration immigration
also is not the number one uh topic for
an election correctly you know Bill
Clinton was right it's the economy
stupid but right behind it you've got
immigration because on one side people
see excess immigration on here maybe
taking basic low-paying jobs and taking
jobs away from the people that are
already here who desperately want to
find those jobs on the other hand you
pointed out that that it actually helps
Innovation when actually information
I've seen this at the H1B program and I
don't know how you got to Harvard and
how you came to the United States but
you you look at a lot of these um
leaders and innovators in Silicon Valley
they came across some h-1bs from India
and and places like this where they had
strong undergraduate degrees and we're
coming for graduate degrees and mbas
here right now when you look at
immigration you were saying it's good
for the economy but it doesn't it create
an immediate deficit burden because when
they arrive here they're not ready to be
workers and it's not a handful of
innovators entrepreneurs coming to start
companies that's a mass of humanity
that's basically Refugee status so most
recently you talked to that on CNBC can
you unpack that a little bit because it
seemed like you were you were talking on
both
sides yeah I mean first of all I would
say that uh you know migration has to be
regulated nobody says let's have open
board that anybody can get in and we
have to have more Ral migration policy
and I would say both parties have
positions that are too radical
essentially Republican blaming every
problem on on migrants and Democrats not
being willing to maybe having more
constraints of how we manage legal
migration as opposed to a more open
border but even Democrats are going to
realize that uh you know you have to
address this problem in a more
consistent way and even Biden I'll say
want funding for the
wall and for a more rational migration
policy so hopefully if we don't make it
a political issue both sides can reach
an agreement on having good quality
workers coming to us and legal migration
rather than illegal one you know us as a
country has always been built on people
coming from from abroad uh migrants you
know everybody in the US came from
somewhere else apart from the Native
American ones uh and and the strength of
the US has been getting people from all
over the world and it's not just that
people say do people come here like me
go to go and get a PhD and being high
productivity workers as opposed to those
who are people with less skills but
think of it this way even among those
that are maybe lower skilled suppose
that you are a poor farmer in Mexico or
Central America and you are deciding to
leave your village
risk your life because you could be dead
cross the border to come to America even
among those Farmers you are the one that
is slightly more entrepreneurial
slightly more risk-taking slightly more
hardworking and you're willing to risk
your life to have a better life in us
and when you come to us you're not going
to get a welfare check you're gonna work
your ass off in the fields in the
factories delivery of food whatever not
I mean we see it see all these Latinos
that provide us service every day I see
in New York in tons of them and I'm sure
whether it's Texas or California these
are really hardworking people that
actually they work hard uh they pay
taxes because they have to pay tax some
of them even pay social security taxes
because they hope that one day they'll
become legal and they have social
security benefits and and therefore
whether there is a PhD like me high
productivity or someone is going to
create a Silicon Valley firm and a good
third of them were created by foreigners
or even a small Campesino that working
is ass off to have a better life and so
on the kind of people that the US
attracts are those that are more
ambitious more entrepreneurial more
staking more hardworking more willing to
have a better life at any level of
education at any level of skills are
there some people that are coming here
maybe because eventually they think
they're gonna get welfare something yes
are the majority I don't think so think
the majority want to come here to work
and have a better life now you cannot
have it unregulated you cannot have
millions of people illegally uh they put
some pressure on local public services
whether it's housing Health Care
education and other ones and therefore
we have to have a managed process so we
have to go beyond the extremes we have
to be rational about it sensible do
immigration reform essenti allow those
who are still here and work hard to be
legalized and then system that allows
people to come in in us legally maybe
you do like Canada where you give points
for skills of some sort you know we
don't need just PhD we need people who
can be electrician or plumbers or
working in the farms and so on so skills
is different a different level of of the
distribution of the job matching as well
so so we have to have a little bit less
rhetoric less
partisanship and you know I'm a migrant
you're a migrant many others are at some
point everybody came from somewhere else
to America and that's what made America
great but we have to have a rational
approach to it we cannot just uh call
them all rapists and murderers and bad
ombres like Trump did that was sick
that's totally false and wrong but we
cannot just have borders are open
without any legal migration either so we
have to tone down the rhetoric and we
have to and by the way there's a massive
lack of supply of labor you know in New
York where I live many restaurants uh
you know don't have enough workers and
skilled workers so you have all these
people coming from Venezuela by the way
many of them are skilled they're
escaping Maduro and economic disaster
and they want to work until recently it
couldn't work because if you come in us
and you're not yet officially uh a
refugee you cannot have a work permit
luckily I think rightly so the Biden
Administration decided that they can
have a work permit because these people
are actually highly employable many of
them are highly employable they want to
work once they're here so if you let
them in we should let them work and
legalize their ability to work so that
they're not a strain on our social
welfare system that's the right thing to
do I just want to hear what restate what
I think you said so you're for legal
immigration you're not for leaving the
Border open and letting everybody in
that's what you're saying you're not for
illegal immigration okay so that's very
important to say for legal immigration
and also for system maybe of points that
gives we need different people of
different skills uh and different skills
means that not everybody is
entrepreneur we need more Farm worker we
need more plumber we need more
electrician we need people who doing
blue collor work in manufacturing so
skills are skills at every Spectrum so
it's not as if you just give a premium
to people have college degree we need
skill workers even though are blue cers
I love that I love and I agree because
we do need there's certain work that not
everybody's is going to do we need we
need people across the board but to to
to specify that you're for legal
immigration and and what's interesting
is what I love what going on is at first
you know a lot of uh Democrats and you
know Republicans criticize democrats for
other things and Democrats criticize
Republicans for other things I love to
see how initially so many Democrats were
against the wall and I'm so impressed
with Biden that he sets aside his ego uh
and the embarrassment for the Democratic
party and he's agreeing to continue
building the wall because he's realizing
how catastrophic it is at the border and
uh maybe maybe the verbiage because you
know I'm a 1978 kid so murial boatlift
when it happened in Miami Jimmy Carter
is the reason why I'm in America you're
probably in America for different
reasons I'm here because of Jimmy Carter
Jimmy Carter's entire campaign was
around human rights and at that time it
was like no hey Resa palav you're an
evil man you're an evil leader you have
to let go to 3,000 political prisoners
well you know a lot of those people they
let go eventually 9/11 happened and many
of those leaders were from the political
prisoners that he had held U hostage in
Iran and then the same thing happened
with Cuba when it was kind of like hey
you know it's not fair what you're doing
to all your political prisoners and then
came one of the greatest movies of all
time called Scarface and he came up and
he says I'm a political Refugee and
guess who Castro sent to Miami he sent
the people out of prison 125,000 people
out of his jail said you go to Miami and
Miami's unemployment rate rate hit
nearly 50% I don't know if youve I'm
sure you've studied what happened to
Miami when he send it so a part of what
Trump was saying he was saying they're
sending not their best is what they're
sending and he's talking about how
Mexico needs to do a better job creating
a better economy so people don't want to
leave your country and come to America
and then you know I was so enamored by a
book I read about how Indians rais their
kids to become leaders I spoke in Mumbai
with atti bachara who was the former
chairwoman of State Bank of India
240,000 employees and I spoke with dang
turak and couple billionaires from there
we were at uh IIT I'm sure you're
familiar with IIT Institute which is
like our MIT but they Crush our MIT many
times when they're doing different kind
of testing and uh you know when you when
you say immigrants when it comes on to
Fortune 500 immigrants a lot of the CEOs
are either Indian uh they're either
Asian uh they're either it's different
kind of uh uh or they're from Venezuela
or they're from uh you know so it's
folks that came here legally that
couldn't stand their country that
eventually work their way up to doing
what they're doing which is great we
want to see that and a lot of times you
know especially with what's going on
right now I think they found Rob what do
they find at the border the the four
Iranian extremist or terrorists that are
coming through the border and the FED
just recently gave us an update two days
ago talking about that there's a high
likelihood that Hezbollah Hamas uh folks
are coming through the southern border
and we have to be careful about it so I
think that is becoming a very big
concern for family saying look you know
uh tragedy you know for example
sometimes Revenge uh uh is done by
people that are patient they'll wait 5
years 10 years 15 years and then all of
a sudden when you least expect it 9/11
happens when you least expect it an
event in Israel happens when you least
expect it so it's uh but the best part
you know while I'm saying all these
things about you about uh Biden what I
love about what I'm seeing with Biden is
Biden has is shown he has no ego giving
credit to and and obviously he's not
giving credit but following Trump's
policies that worked and he's following
with it whether it's the semiconductor
chip policies that he had you know
whether it's different kind of things
that he was doing there it's great to
see the other side about immigration
that I want to kind of ask the question
to you and maybe this is just my lack of
expertise in this area I want to see
what you'll say about it you know how on
one end you'll say we we need more
immigrants we need to have more
immigrants comeing here I agree I think
we need to have more kids I don't think
we're having enough kids I think we need
to have more babies uh I think one of
the biggest problems we have in America
is Americans are not having enough kids
we're having too few kids we need to be
having more kids and that's a problem
that can be that math can be shown in
many different ways but if we're saying
we need more immigrants to come here and
these are your words where you're saying
we need more immigrants to come here
that's fine I agree but then on the
other end you also think that AI is
going to dest destroy a lot of jobs
where they're going to rely on you know
what's the thing that Andrew Yang was
talking about we had him on the podcast
the the $1,000 a month he called it
something it was Ubi Universal basic
income Universal basic income so isn't
that kind of contradictory to think on
one end and maybe that's normal it's
okay to to entertain both thoughts to
say we need more immigrants yes because
they're willing to do some works and
then on the other end we're like yeah
but AI is going to replace a lot of
jobs um that's a very valid and
important point I think the answer of it
it's over which time Horizon you're
worried about which problem I would say
that today the job disruption caused by
AI are extremely limited and if anything
the fact that there are going to be
hundreds or thousands of new AI firms
created living like the internet
startups and and so on may actually
create many more jobs because there'll
be lots of new firms trying to do Ai and
they require workers of different
skills uh so in the short run actually
there'll be a booming capital investment
by the Us corporate sector because every
firm is going to have to say I want to
you know invest into AI not to fall
behind and they're going to need people
that actually know about Ai and can
implement it as a first stage and the
unemployment rate in US is very low uh
really .7% by any historical standard
has been strong job creation both in
manufacturing in
Services the chip act the infrastructure
act the IRA is going to create many more
jobs whether in manufactoring whether in
fossil fuel and renewable energy whether
construction work for infrastructures
and you nameit so so and right now we
have actually T tight labor market and
there's been a fall in labor force
participation rate aging of population
and we also need more workers because
our social security system and Medicare
is pay as you
go and the payroll taxes of the young
pay for the benefits of the elderly and
now we have less young people more old
people and the Social Security trust
fund is going to run out of money in a
decade and the only way to avoid it is
either you have more babies but people
cannot force them to have more children
I agree with you so have more children
but for whole bunch of reason people
don't or the other option is immigration
immigration has helped us with this
implicit debt or unfunded liability
coming from pay you go Healthcare and
social security system over the next 10
years I think that there'll be really a
demand for jobs and there's got to be a
scarcity of job giving aging giv the
great resignation and so on so uh
immigration is going to be necessary in
the next 10 years or so as there'll be
more AI there'll be disruptions there'll
be job loss in manufacturing job loss in
Services even cognitive not creative
jobs and eventually probably if you're
looking not next 10 years but 20 years
you could have a a significant amount of
permanent technological unemployment
that's the bad news the good news is
that AI is going to increase
productivity growth it's going to
increase potential growth that today is
only 2% potential growth become four
five six seven and therefore eventually
you can tax the winners and then
redistribute money to those who are left
behind not because they're lazy or
whatever but because they're unlucky and
they are in firms and jobs that are made
obsolete by AI so that's exactly what
Universal basic income is going to be
you tax the winners you tax the robots
you tax those who gain from Ai and you
distribute to those that need to be
reskilled or need to be supported with
other social safety net but I would say
in the next decade we're going to need
more jobs more people we have aging we
have unfunded liabilities we have
bottlenecks on the labor market on terms
of Supply being low and demand being
high so we need migrants if and when uh
productivity growth from AI is going to
cause massive job disruption massive
technology and unemployment and we don't
need all those foreign workers then we
can reduce the amount of people we H let
in from abroad maybe significantly over
time we might need still skilled workers
right you know to do AI to do the jobs
of the future to do data science let me
push back a little bit on that though
China is every year 1.3 million people
graduating in computer science and
engineering uh a multiple of what we do
in the US so we might still need lots of
Engineers from India to help us to build
a ey so so let me push back on that on a
couple different fronts
yeah on on one and and I want you to if
I push back and you're like you're you
have no idea what you're talking about
push back as much as you can I I want to
find Leakes of my argument um so you're
saying we still need immigrants okay
fine we need immigrants but at the same
time the rich people we're going to have
to over tax them to pay the others
because they got unlucky but we need
people because in other countries
they're getting degrees in areas that is
high paying jobs so why are are we
entertaining the idea of allowing
everybody and anybody to come here
America back in the days was about what
do you bring to our country what do you
offered to our country we recruited and
allowed the best to come here like the
best of the best the best Minds the best
educated people nowadays we're getting
people that are coming to our schools
learning our stuff then they're going
back to their countries they used to
stay here now they're like nah I don't
know if I want to stay here anymore I
want to go back to my country and uh you
know and then the other the other thing
about social security and what are we
going to do within the next 10 years I
have a thought why don't we uh when we
came out with social security retirement
age was 65 whatever it was and people
life expectancy was 62 the benefit was
barely being paid for a few hundred if
not a few thousand people now we're
paying a ton of different people how
about the idea of doing the following
okay is raising retirement age to 72
Social Security doesn't start till 72
however there's a big however and I want
to see uh what your uh how you would uh
uh break down this argument and say Noah
I don't think it's going to work what if
we raise so a retirement age where
Social Security benefits start at 72
however from 65 years old on every year
you make money up to $200,000 salary you
pay no taxes what does that mean so I'm
sitting there with my wife I'm 65 years
old I'm about to take Social Security I
say babe we can't afford this guess what
what I'll work for another year but this
year if I work I won't pay federal
income taxes and I'll work one more year
and I'll work one more year and I'll
work one more year and I'll work one
more year every year you're delaying the
benefits of Social Security which is a
good thing and as long as you choose to
do that great but Social Security
doesn't start till 72 this may cause
some young people I I know people right
now that are 80 years old that are very
young they're they look like they're 60
years old it's a very different climate
today but I think I think there's some
contradictions in that argument of we
need immigrants but we need more educat
but if we don't then we have to pay the
Unlucky ones and get the people that are
creating the jobs to tax them even
higher that doesn't really excite people
to you know pursue incentives knowing
the ones that are going to work above
and beyond and find Solutions are going
to get destroyed by the government taxes
long term don't you
think uh you make many valid arguments
and I think that as we often agree is
never black and white is a matter of
tradeoffs so it's not no immigration or
totally open border it's not like AI is
going to destroy jobs toor more as
opposed to eventually destroy jobs and
there are many ways in which you can
resolve the problem of P you go Social
Security and healthare uh systems one is
as you suggest increasing retirement age
and other one is to give incentive
including tax ones like you suggested to
work longer you could gradually raise
the payroll tax you could gradually
reduce even the benefits not of the
currently old or the one to soon to be
retired by the benefits
of people so it's a combination of
things that you can do to resolve this
problem and we'll need to make them
unfortunately neither party wants to
make entitlement reform is the third
rail of us politics you know Democrats
say let's not touch Social Security
that's right but Trump knows that he
toxic to talk about social security and
he doesn't want to talk about it he says
the other Republican candidates want to
reform Social Security are stupid so
both parties are in denial and
unfortunately it's going to take
eventually a crisis getting closer to
running out of the trust fund and we're
going to need the bipartisan commission
like we did in the 80s with Greenspan
running it to try to reform Social
Security but until we get to the problem
that we're running out of money nothing
is going to be done because both sides
are going to be pretending that it's not
a problem uh so entitlement is a big
issue and the kind of things you suggest
definitely go in direction of what uh we
need to do but we're not going to do
anything for the next 10 years and
meanwhile having skilled workers who
come generate income pay payroll taxes
and then they make this problem less
severe is one of the solution if we
don't have more babies more migrants as
a result this unfunded liability all
over the world don't you think T I said
you know on on migration we agree it's
not black and white we don't want to
shut down the Border we don't want to
leave it open to everybody we need
skilled workers and for the next decade
I would say the demand for workers is
outstrip the supply and the bottleneck
is going to be we don't have enough
worker qualified for the jobs that we
need and unless we have more skilled
work in US unless we have more babies
going to take 20 years anyhow for these
babies to become adults we need more
workers from abroad I would do a reform
of our migration policy that first is
legal migration that you get points for
different types of skills and we need
both manual workers blue color workers
white color workers entrepreneurial so
the kind of points you get depend on
what are our bottlenecks in which
sectors and we're going to have more of
them and those who want to come to us as
I said usually are those who are more
entrepreneurial more ambitious more RIS
taking more willing to leave family
Society tribe Village and start their
life from scratch like you did like I
did right and those who are actually
staying back home or those who are maybe
less entrepreneurial less ambitious less
reaking less hardworking right so
actually us gets the best of all when
they get the migrants overall with few
bad apples but the bad apples tend to be
the exception and the Good Apples tend
to be the good ones that's what made
America great again and then even when a
is gonna really destroy lots of jobs
then we'll have to figure out phase out
migration and regardless of migration
eventually AI is going to destroy so
many jobs that there is no other
solution but taxing the winners and
redistributing to those who lost jobs
because they were unlucky So eventually
we're GNA have Ubi and eventually we'll
have some Universal basic provision of
Public Services if not Ubi because there
is no other way otherwise inequality is
going to go to the roof and you'll have
massive social Strife so in a democracy
eventually if there is permanent
technological unemployment that is not
your own fault but because of Technology
we have to tax the winners and
redistribute like we do in any
Progressive social welfare system like
in the west not just Europe but also in
the US we already do it now we have to
do it in a more systematic way there's
no other alternative otherwise you have
you have a
revolution well I think what you're
saying is very interesting 10 years is
not a long Horizon I mean think about it
10 years ago Obama was in his second
term we think of him as maybe just the
president the other day but 10 years ago
he was in his second term uh he had a
chef and we've got now what you seem to
be describing as a labor bubble that's
going to happen over the the next 10
years I like what you're saying about a
point system for skills to moderate um
uh immigration to those people you know
give us your tired you're poor your
huddle masses yearning debris free and
bringing those over what you seem to be
describing that is that there would be a
labor bubble that's going to lead to
acceleration of socialist
policies is that is that kind of the
crystal ball you're
seeing well what what they see is a
situation in which income and wealth
inequality this reason real wages lag
behind workers have done less than
people who are entrepreneur owner or
capital or very high skill worker and of
course the the right solution is not
taxing the rich and redistributing but
giving Economic Opportunity so
reskilling education investing into
restoring of manufacturing
infrastructure AI you name it policies
that lead to more jobs and more good
jobs and and again not to be partisan
doesn't matter whether a trump is going
to do it or a Biden is going to do it we
need sound industrial policy that
rebuild the job and Industrial base our
country I think whoever is going to be
EMP power have to go in that direction
we have to make sure we are not
excessively
protectionist excessively against
migration uh because migration is going
to help us to deal with some of those
challenges we need rational economic
policies and we can go in the right
direction and If eventually AI is going
to destroy many jobs the economic p is
going to be so big that we can
redistribute to those who are left
behind or res skill them so so we have
to manage all these
transitions with a rational migration
policy with rational reform of
entitlements and Social Security and
with a rational industrial policy uh as
well um the uh uh
Dr rubini this has been fantastic really
enjoy talking to you uh uh Rob if we can
make sure we put Mega threats link below
with all the links to uh uh social
before we wrap up uh 30 seconds Dr Rin I
know you talked about it briefly earlier
what should what will the readers uh get
from the book if you don't mind uh
taking 30 seconds and sharing with us
what's in the
book well the book speaks not only about
the economic monetary and financial
threats but as I said the political
inequality and backlash against liberal
democracy geopolitical the risk of war
between great nation the technological
one how much AI is gonna produce more as
opposed to disrupt jobs the risk coming
from climate change and we have to
address them to save the planet how to
address Global pandemics are becoming
more severe the backlash against
globalization so what are the policy we
can have to avoid the dystopian future
where these economic and non-economic
threats feed on each other and we end up
in a dystopian future I think we can do
it but we have to start waking up stop
living like zombies stop kicking the
count down the road and all the solution
this problem exist but they require
sacrifices individually socially
collectively in the short run for the
common good nationally and globally over
time so we have to be less divided less
partisan most of American actually I
think are mainstream the radicals on the
right and the left are the minority we
have to be together because the problems
we're addressing are serious nationally
and globally together we can resolve
them we swim and survive together or we
sing together we're all in the same boat
so but we have to address them
individually and collectively and stop
partisanship polarization and division
that's what can weaken America America
is strong economically technologically
even militarily what can actually
destroy America is internal division
partisanship and
polarization thank you so much sir again
gang the Link's going to be below to
order the book uh uh appreciate you take
care everybody bye-bye bye-bye
bye-bye great being with
you